10 en direct pour parler qu'ovide
variant pas sanitaire karim khelfaoui
médecin généraliste à marseille
bonjour karim khelfaoui merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
130 passion qu'ovide en hôpitaux
universitaires à marseille dont 35 en
réanimation
le plan blanc a été déclenché et
également en région paca on constate une
forte activité du grenat virus dans des
zones précises prisées par les
vacanciers donc comme la côte d'azur
l'occitanie ou encore les dom-tom on l'a
vu avec avec ce reportage
comment est-ce que vous expliquer cette
hausse le tourisme le manque de
vigilance le variant delta une
couverture vaccinale insuffisante alors
c'est un cocktail un petit peu c'est à
dire que effectivement on est chassé
invariants qui est plus contagieux donc
il a tendance à beaucoup huit diffusée
et à côté de ça oriente destivelle comme
vous l'avez très bien dit jc dans les
périodes où il ya fort tourisme que on
voit apparaître cette situation
sanitaire dégradée en avance par rapport
à supplier parce que vous allez voir que
dans les semaines à venir
ça va se généraliser partout c'est ce
qui s'était déjà passé l'année dernière
où on a notamment le gouvernement avait
pointé du doigt les marseillais à la fin
de l'été en disant qu'ils étaient
irresponsables et que la situation
sanitaire haché été dégradée en raison
des responsabilités alors qu'en réalité
c'était l'effet du tourisme de masse
pendant l'été qu'on était en train de
payer et la situation s'est généralisé
ensuite dans les semaines qui ont suivi
donc c'est ce qui va se reproduire à mon
avis dans les semaines qui viennent les
chiffres de la vaccination sont pourtant
assez encourageant en france on a
l'impression pourtant de ressentir donc
pas en ressentir les effets alors
comment expliquer ça est-ce que la
situation serait pire sans la
vaccination ou
votre analyse je pense qu'effectivement
la situation serait pire sans la
destination en maintenant il faut bien
dire une chose c'est que l'hôpital
public les hôpitaux en général et le
système des samples en général n'ont pas
été renforcée depuis un an le
gouvernement a fait la sourde oreille à
balayer ça d'un revers de la main même
continuer à fermer des lits y compris
des lits de réanimation
on a le canard enchaîné qui nous a
révélé récemment qui a eu je crois 700
800 lits ont été fermés de réalisation
en moins d'un an en ile de france
donc on est en pleine pandémie et on
continue avec un dogme libéral qui
constitue qui consiste à tuer les
services publics petit à petit et ça
c'est pas possible donc aujourd'hui on
est face à une situation sanitaire qui
est dégradée dans des hôpitaux qui sont
sous tension en permanence et même avant
le coup vite
donc en réalité on arrive extrêmement
rapidement à saturation de nos hôpitaux
parce que il fonctionne comme ça il
fonctionne en flux tendu en permanence
donc on n'a aucune marge de manoeuvre
est justement les marges de manoeuvre à
la rentrée ou à l'automne ça pourrait
être quoi de nouvelles mesures de
restriction avec déconfinement locaux un
peu comme ce qui se fait en guadeloupe
ou en martinique
déjà c'est de nouveau à des programmes
et c'est ce qui est en train de s'opérer
ici à marseille et donc de la france
donc deux nouveaux jours on va avoir des
retards de prise en charge et des
motards diagnostic pour un certain
nombre de patients parce qu'on n'a pas
mis le paquet pour renforcer le système
de santé français et à côté de ça
effectivement on va se retrouver sans
doute dans une situation à l'automne
dans les mois qui viennent ou le
gouvernement n'aura probablement pas le
choix soit il devra faire là
la sourde oreille et faire comme s'il
n'y avait pas de problème sanitaire et
en disant tout va bien circulez ya rien
à voir
ce qui est une possibilité puisque à un
an des présidentielles on ne sait pas
comment le président macron va gérer
cette année karim ou alors ils vont être
honnête et dire va effectivement la
situation était gardé et le pass and i
ter n'a absolument rien réglé en réalité
ce pass sanitaires c'est la ligne
maginot face au coc u19
ça ne sert strictement à rien ça ne va
rien arrivé on va pas avoir de davantage
sanitaire avec ça le seul intérêt
c'était en fait de pousser les gens à
l'accélération de les contrats dans la
fac six nations sans endosser la
responsabilité juridique d'une
obligation personnel voilà la réalité
c'est donc justement par rapport à 7 237
mille manifestants anti-pape sanitaires
hier en france
comment est-ce que vous réagissez y en a
beaucoup qui refusent de se faire
vacciner qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez je leur réponds que ils ont ils
ont des raisons d'avoir des méfiances en
particulier quand on a un pouvoir comme
ça que gaël complètement discrédité n'a
pas arrêté de mentir mais il ne faut pas
confondre le geste de la détention avait
plongé et la musique à ce qu'il en est
pourtant contre la colite 19 ce n'est
pas le miracle que le gouvernement est
en train de décrire parce qu'un jour ou
l'autre on va se rendre compte que ça va
pas suffire indiqué la situation et si
cela limite énormément les choses en
particulier en termes de 102 pas les 41
ans de contrat je suis cité et ses verts
voit on a des soucis commencent à sortir
on voit que le variant d'état par
exemple dans les premiers jours de
réflexion d'une personne vaccinée mais
on peut être très contagieuse aussi là
contrairement à ce que raconte le père
la mort donc il faut faire attention
c'est la meilleure a répondu aujourd'hui
il faut ne pas hésiter à l'utiliser
parce qu'elle est sûre elle est efficace
maintenant clairement contraindre les
personnes sans assumer la responsabilité
juridique ça ne marchera pas parce qu'on
va avoir un certain qu'ils ne vont pas
faire actionner et surtout on ne règle
pas ou même majeurs qui est l'accès au
vaccin
ou partie de la population il ya toute
une partie de la population qui est
isolé qui et qui n'a plus de médecin
traitant qui n'a plus de rapport direct
avec le système de santé et qui
aujourd'hui n'a pas accès au vaccin
parce que le vaccin ne va pas donc ça
aussi c'est des choses que le
gouvernement ne veut pas voir
du coup va payer à un moment donné de
parler notamment du variant d'état delta
un mot sur le variant colombien sept
résidents d'une maison de repos décédées
ces derniers jours près de bruxelles
alors qu'ils étaient pourtant vacciner
pas encore de lettre de l'alphabet grec
pour pour cette nouvelle souche est ce
que vous êtes inquiet tout eh oui ce
monde est inquiet maintenant on va
attendre un petit peu d'avoir un peu
plus de recul pour voir ce qui s'est
passé les clairement il faut être très
très net sur quelque chose
la stratégie de vaccination ne peut
avoir un effet que si elle est mondiale
s'il ya une vaccination massive partout
dans le monde en même temps
effectivement on pourrait limiter la
circulation des bus de manière à les
monter le nom du destin qui arrive or ce
n'est pas le cas il ya une immense
majorité les jambes qui allait de la
planète n'a pas au vaccin donc le virus
va continuer à circuler il va continuer
à lutter et quand il va rencontrer les
populations vaccinées nécessairement il
ya certaines mutations qui vont devenir
un avantage sélectif dit elles
permettent à ce virus peut passer dans
la population vaccinée
on sait qu'à un moment un problème
d'efficacité de ces vaccins il sera pas
karine puisqu'on voit sans doute changer
de formule
pervis rappelle qu'en france dans un
pays riche qui c'est un de ceux qui
s'est accaparé l'ensemble des vaccins
disponibles avec les autres pays riches
et b en a mis sept mois pour à peine et
de maxime où la moitié de la population
et que dans le reste du monde cite le
cas il ya un véritable problème avec la
vaccination et il est là donc
aujourd'hui il faut lever sur et vaccins
je veux lever les brevets sur l'ensemble
des recherches et des traitements de
manière à ce que le groupe ne soit parce
que la vie humaine
on est quand même arrivé à hambourg ou à
un président de la république et faire
sacraliser les profits de certaines
multinationales plutôt que
la vie des personnes et notamment des
personnes dans notre pays mais aussi
dedans on pourrait lever les brevets en
france et ils massivement des vagues
molles ou le district de paris merci cam
khalfaoui d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste à marseille